20 years ago the Good Friday Agreement
paved the way for an end to decades of
bitter conflict in Northern Ireland but
the results have been mixed my guest
this week here in Dublin is Bertie Ahern
former Irish prime minister and one of
the co signatories of the agreement in
1998 just how fragile is the peace
process now and what would it take to
get it back on track
[Music]
Bertie Ahern welcome to conflict zone
thank you very much in November 1998 you
told a meeting of your party in a file
that you believe the United island was
irresistible
you spoke way too soon didn't you well I
did I say that in November 1998 by the
moment yeah well I I think we I still
believe united Ireland is it'll happen
but I'm irresistible would be certainly
too strong a word to be to be using I
think united Ireland could happen over a
long period it certainly can't Sam it's
certainly not something that's going to
happen in the short or medium term in my
view and I don't even agree with people
who believe that we should use they the
clause in the agreements to have a
border pole in the short term because it
would be divisive won't be helpful you
said it was a dangerous game last April
you said anybody wants to play that's a
dangerous game that's I certainly said
that and I still and that would apply to
the Irish government at the moment would
it apply to anybody I think to push a
border poll in the short term and it's
not the result because I think I know
what the result would be we reject it
but if it would be the antagonism and
animosities that the campaign would
generate and everything around that what
settings back and when we're trying to
get things to work so I think it
definitely is not the thing so why is
the Irish government pushing it and the
Nationalists are pushing it well they
want to exploit the the weakness of the
power sharing agreement which collapsed
over a year ago
ya know exploit the the uncertainties
and the political drift that's going on
at the moment well in champaign are
pushing it and their line is that they
will do it in a five-year period that
started our latest line and but I have
to correct you the Irish government are
not doing it the guard Irish government
are not pushing it in 2016 you had the
Irish Prime Minister Enda Kenny saying
to the EU get ready for a united Ireland
what was that if it wasn't massively
provocative well I he
if he said that his stated position is
that it's a long-term project I mean he
certainly both both ended that's like
saying the unionist yeah I have to say
if if we put it that way it's not what
his normal position it's his normal
position he's not of my side but I'd
have to defend him I think both Leo
broad care and and the Kenny had said
that they believe the United aren't is a
long-term project the foreign minister
got into some difficulties recently when
he said it would happen in his lifetime
but in furs to him he switched the DUP
condemned as megaphone diplomacy and
he's 46 you know so with the normal life
cycle II thought that could be a yeah
but why come out with these things
I think needlessly provocative I think
the reason is that that's you know
people like you ask them the questions
and they ask them two questions are they
in favor of united Ireland are they not
and what if if you if you say if you say
I'm not in favor of the united Ireland
and I never want to see you in either
Ireland that causes em huge
disappointment for nationís so I think
em III don't criticize politicians for
saying that they believe the aspiration
is for united Ireland I think all of us
would like to see that but I do not
think I'd have to defend at the present
I don't think that in present government
who is taking the view that they think
we should have a short-term border poll
and a short term United you had Leo
vodka the current Irish Prime Minister
saying he understood that certain
statements said by the nationalists have
been seen as disrespectful intrusive or
interfering as he put this was not our
intention he said we have no hidden
agenda have you ever met a politician
Bertie Ahern who didn't have enough too
many well I think they you know in in
the circumstances of Northern Ireland
we're without the institution's for 15
months and I think they the primary
issue for us to do now is in a cool and
a camp edit position to try and get the
institution's back up and running I
think that's what both governments
should be doing I think it's what all
the party should be doing and I think a
cool attitude like Shin fane's where you
get the kind of rhetoric from Gerry
Adams the form of champagne leader
saying I believe the British government
has no right to be in Ireland never had
any right to be in Ireland and never
will have any right to be in Ireland
that's going back to the battle it is it
is what what what happens is I was on a
TV programme to go today and with some
of the extreme unionists and and they
would almost question the rice of of
Gerry Adams to be in Northern Ireland so
I'm afraid that it doesn't help on
either side it and that kind of language
doesn't happen either side but Infernus
you have to do a lot of cool headed
people in both the unionist the nationís
and this week we've had the loyalists
issue in a very positive statement
trying to move away from violence
trying to move or not a move away from
violence but move away from criminality
and the Ulster freedom fighters your
defense Association the red hand
commanders so there are people on all
sides trying hard to to build peace
build relationship but words matter or
what work and what works more than some
some and I don't think you'd argue with
some opportunistically using brexit to
try and unpick the Union nothing well
you get the latent attempt to do just
that though there are there are you're
certainly right in that there are
British politicians and Tory British
politicians who have opted the ante and
big-time like Owen Paterson and others
talking about the people who are causing
the problems and what there there have
been very very unhelpful in trying to
say that they go friday agreement
is not meaningful anymore that it is not
useful that it is creating difficulties
and that if it wasn't there we'd have an
easier break but it's not just the Tory
politicians david trimble the four
master unity that we did it's mainly the
Tory politicians and it is then
responded to I think you have to
understand this it's their British Tory
presentations British Tory politicians
on day David asked the eunice said the
one thing that would provoke loyalist
paramilitary is the present Irish
government saying silly things about the
border and the constitutional issue and
David trim is a good friend of mine but
who is he he's a member of the Tory
party he left the Ulster Unionist Party
and joined the Tory party so an afraid
you've made my case does that neutral
okay just because these are towards is
that deny the right of his statement no
he doesn't but does it make it wrong but
I'm just quoting back and afraid and
afraid you walked into a sorry walked
into it you said that there are other
politicians but very politician you
quoted there was an Ulster Unionist
politician I am saying but I am saying
if you were if you want an argument I
give it to you and I win so I I just
want to tell you that what we need is
Kam good headed politicians and to try
to make the Good Friday Agreement work
and what I'm saying to you is that Tory
politicians who are using breakfast
because you ask the question are
creating the difficulty those of us I'm
not politician any longer but those of
us who are trying to keep things calm
and keeps him sane are saying to them
that is the wrong thing to do we must
work together to get his solution that
makes the brexit work if that's what the
British want and that's what they vote
over and we I accept that but Iran isn't
cool and and and clever to keep Hawking
on about the fact that 56 percent of
Northern Ireland voted to remain in the
EU and if they would only unite with
Ireland their membership of the EU would
be assured is it cool and clever to
keep on with this delight at the EU
Parliament's vote last year to give
Northern Ireland special EU status this
is sheer hypocrisy Familia from the
Irish government doesn't but I'm sorry
I'm sorry
and the the British Parliament did not
folk last year to give special you poo
Parliament are not the negotiator says
you know and adulation without a Tod we
went it like what we're delighted with
is that the European ago she aters are
saying that and the border in Ireland
would be a huge disadvantage so we're
delighted us which everybody has said
haven't been the Tories have said that
government has said that the EU has said
the Irish government has said it so so
why make brexit into this disaster it
doesn't have to be dunno if Brett if if
Britain and others seem to delight in
warning that this is politics taken
delight at all I mean III I'm just
worried for the British people I think
if the British people stay in the
customs union it solves the British
problem there's lots of salty hours
problem I can't understand why the
British public would want to and support
the customs union I think people like
Ken Clark and a former you know foreign
leader of the of the authorities of that
they have made sensible issues that
sustained across viewing is the right
thing to do and and I think in the end
it won't be called the customs union I
think Theresa May will probably try him
maneuver a party to stay in the clothes
from Union as well or somewhere near but
you seem to blow hot and cold on this
issue because one moment you say take to
resume at her word you told the Irish
Times last November she's confidently
said she doesn't want a physical border
the you don't want a physical border
Irish government don't and then you say
in a recent interview
got to play hardball with the Brits know
what different thing I like no I'll
explain to you why Theresa May said on
the 15th of December that she was quite
happy to have a backstop and that would
and make sure there was no border and
less than three months later she said
that no British Prime Minister could
agree a backstop that she agreed 10 to
15 to December so am I meant to praise
somebody for taking a different position
in ten weeks if Theresa May is
consistent I would be our first
supporter but the British ambassador in
Washington last month saying the UK
remain committed to protecting
north-south cooperation and to its
guarantee of avoiding a hard border he
said that last month yeah well I mean
let's see if they stick to that but if
they stick to a consistent position what
what we do in Ireland and I think you
understand the better than most we've
had eight hundred years of British Miss
rule and we don't trust them very well
and we never did and we got the Good
Friday Agreement which we want to
implement and so when the British
government say something we like to see
it done and we don't go around trusting
them and after 800 years very easy so
what happened to all this fine talk over
the last couple of weeks about the trust
surrounding the Good Friday Agreement
and all the north-south institutional
bodies and all this you're saying
there's no trust there well we don't
have the institutions up and running you
know in the great 20 years we don't the
way fully don't have now and that's and
that's why we raised so all the mistrust
is back no and not all the mistrust is
back but we have we have a hundred years
of misrule 800 years of bad misrule
priorities and I get my branch outside
of Ireland to get the Brits out of
Ireland every bank that directedness
it's all I mean what you need to do
spend some more time in Ireland you
might understand this because you seem
badly informed if you don't mind me
saying but no we work very closely with
the British government but we don't love
the consistency of the British
government I mean we we
to see and brexit Duff works for us and
if it works for Britain as well that's
fine
we want to see north-south buddies that
work well we want to see the east-west
relationship to work well and I think
it's a pity that we will lose the
contact we presently have with British
politicians after the 29th of March next
and we've had very good relationships
with British politicians for 45 years in
Europe when Britain leaves the yeah but
that ends unfortunately when when they
leave the EU we won't have that regular
contact of every week and every month of
meeting them now I think if we get the
institution's back up and running again
we can use the intergovernmental
conference of the Good Friday Agreement
to actually do that and I think there's
a solution in the Good Friday Agreement
and to deal with and he d UK be noted EU
and I think that will work for both of
us but you heard looking back over the
Good Friday process the problem has been
more reconciliation than peace hasn't it
although we'll come on to peace in a
minute but a lack of political will man
the politicians to make reconciliation
work I'm thinking of Education out of
more than 1,100 schools in Northern
Ireland just 65 are integrated yes it's
a very because it's a very small
proportion very very very small
proportion there wasn't be in the will
on either side and I I think to
reconcile it day with some communities
and they have made enormous progress in
other areas very little progress
integrated education is certainly one of
those problems there's no doubt about
that and you have to blame the
politicians who were put into power by
the Good Friday and no it's a
politicians don't decide what schools
children go to parents decide what
schools children they can either push
integration when they Infernus a lot of
politicians are trying to do that but a
parents decide to follow their
denominational grounds and you know
politicians can't force them but in that
whole last month commissioned by the
integrated education fund people blamed
political leaders for doing little or
nothing
to bring about integrated education
nearly 80% they wanted cross community
merges of schools but they blamed
politicians and incidentally the
churches as well for holding up the
process yeah but but you know it's not
my job tighter defend politicians in the
North or the churches both if people if
people want to to force your people into
integrated education like if I take this
example if I was to force the large
Muslim population now in Dublin to join
up with integration education what would
you and others be saying to that and you
know so we can't just force but you're
working with a particular history and
you can't force and and it's because of
that history and I would like to see
more integrated education I think would
certainly help what had future
generations and but you can't force
parents to pull away from what they they
like and what their comfortable ways you
can promote it my point is that no I
think there is been promoting it look at
look at housing look at social housing
for instance 90 percent of social
housing estates are still single
identity single religion but but in
fairness to the politicians on all sides
they are trying her to do that that they
are and I do get the peace walls the
so-called peace walls down the barriers
in Catholic communities they're third
more of them than there were time the
good friday and they're effectively open
and people are moving cross by back and
fall without too much difficulty I think
the politicians in the north would would
certainly improve the situation if they
were working together
in the institutions to promote more
reconciliation there's no doubt about
that there's no doubt about that but
they it can only be done in the context
of Northern Ireland and its history and
the division and the divided society it
can only be done slowly and in the
meantime I think we have to very much
support and promote the kind of peace
programs and cross border cross
community programs that are there
and there are many politicians in the
north working very hard with communities
and I have been in the Shankill where
I've and the Falls where I've seen
Catholic kids played the lamb bagged
Rome I've seen Protestant kids play the
fiddle
I've seen them trying to promote Harling
so there are lots of people you know
trying trying to do this thing
I think they consider doing it fast
enough no are they concerned enough
about the violence because if you look
at the 10 years - April 2016 there were
1,100 bombings and shootings almost 800
so-called punishment attacks and 4,000
people who were pushed out of their
homes in Northern Ireland when in the 10
years - April 2016 no no - these are
figures compiled from Belfast
detailed data website wasn't heard from
police prison court records have hardly
been a bombing there's hardly been a
bombing in Northern Ireland since the
Omagh bombing last year according to the
Police Service of Northern Ireland there
were a hundred and one shootings and
beatings up from just 60 for four years
but most of those have not been
political there's been more people I
give you one thing and you're not
concerned about this no I'll tell you
there's or has been a feud between two
gangs in Dublin in the last three years
more people have been killed in that
than in Northern Ireland in the last 15
years there the figures and the bombing
campaign in Northern Ireland
OMA was last significant bombing or very
there's very very little political
shootings in Northern Ireland and in the
lower third is still criminality but
unafraid the criminality is what happens
in every city criminality will not end
on the political solution but as far as
political violence in Northern Ireland
there's little or none or husband
husband Italy and the shootings and
beatings are okay other lourdes
shootings and beatings are happening
everywhere and we shooting them I was
watching the television the other day
and the crisis the huge crisis in London
particularly there's less crime in
Northern Ireland that underlays practic
practically complacent about no I'm not
the table and I have to say your your
figures are from cloud cuckoo-land
well these are figures as I said how
fast detail detail data webs near the
must been late at night when they gave
them but I mean there's little or no
shootings in Northern Ireland and little
or no but there is criminal activity
criminal activity and which which were
always worried about we have that in
this city here where we were unisys and
there's been about ten borders in the
line in the last two years around just
around this area and what is nothing to
do political violence it's to do with
criminals and drugs but in the years
since the Good Friday Agreement your own
fortunes have been mixed in 2012 you
resigned from your party after a public
inquiry said you've lied about the
source of substantial sums of money that
you'd received you said you'd gone clear
your name did you clear yes I did I'm
quite happy I cleared my name because
the tribunal never reversed its decision
no I made a tribunal the tribunal gave
its views and a tribunal gave it's
truthful no they gave its views and I
gave my evidence and I gave my evidence
and I was very happy with my evidence
and I was very happy with the situation
that that I gave and a tribunal is over
as reported you understand why they
thought yeah I knew like I do i dint Det
I dealt with that issue and I'm not
saying any more about that issue I dealt
with it comprehend finance minister with
that I think I have dealt with all those
issues comprehensively I'm not dealing
with them again you're somebody who
wants to come back maybe as president
these are issues I debate for another
day that'd be for another day for a
senior politician who was always to
avoid not only impropriety but the
appearance I've given him I've given my
total views in that issue and I'm not
going to add to them let me talk about
the crash the economic crash yes the
tribunal verdict on you can I just for
you and I just explained for a minister
to you why you don't want to talk about
no I want to tell you I agree to meet
you in the Good Friday Agreement we've
done that so we're finished thank you
very much all right
with that mr. Aherne cut short the
interview and left the room conflict
zone is a difficult program for
politicians it isn't meant after all to
be easy we had no intention of offending
him this was billed as an interview
about the Good Friday Agreement but we
did also offer his office a list of
topics that we were going to cover but
they didn't come back to us we hope mr.
Ahern will come back to us someday and
finish the interview and we wish him
well for the future
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]